now to the fires in California the
Kincaid fire burning north of San
Francisco is now 70% contained in the
South evacuation orders are starting to
live for thousands of residents forth
from their homes by the Morea fire in
Ventura County video from a fire camera
purports to show the moment the fire
ignited on Thursday the possibility that
Maria was sparked by a re-energized
power line is under investigation that
fire has destroyed more than 10,000
acres and is not contained the forecast
does call for calm winds today which may
help the fire fight but for homeowners
confronted with the increased fire
threats and evacuations there is another
danger the inability to get insurance
here's Carter Evans most of the homes
destroyed in California's recent
wildfires were covered by insurance but
now the owners of the homes left
standing when the wind starts to blow
like this do you get concerned always
yes our being financially burned
Frances man Craig is among at least 350
thousand Californians whose fire
insurance policies have been canceled
she had the same coverage for 18 years
I've paid thousands and thousands of
dollars in premiums and insurance and
never gotten a cent back
now she's scrambling to find coverage as
is Kathleen Hart a 14-year policyholder
never made a claim never had any issues
and had Oh coffee you've lived here 25
years have you ever had any trouble
getting insurance before this no not at
all
but as wildfires in California get worse
insurance companies are limiting their
exposure in fire prone areas they've
paid more than twenty four billion
dollars in claims in just the past two
years can you understand it from the
insurers perspective last year they paid
out almost double what they took in on
premiums that's why you're in the
insurance business sometimes you break
in the dough and sometimes you pay
people that have invested their income
in you for years Fire Insurance is still
available but at an exorbitant price
just under $19,000 a year a year $19,000
and you were paying 3800 before correct
rising premiums are pricing people out
of their homes despite efforts to
fireproof their properties Oh coffee
even installed her own water tanks and
fire hydrant they inspected my property
three years ago and gave us an A+ rating
but they wouldn't even pull that report
out of their files no one's come to my
house to look at what I've done it we
are constantly trimming trees cutting
back trees we have a volunteer fire
department in our neighborhood it sounds
like you're very proactive homeowners
yes it's awful and it's frustrating
California Insurance Commissioner
Ricardo Laura says it's time for action
except we don't have that authority yet
many people are receiving cancellation
notices right now and this is the peak
of fire season they're terrified without
expressive statutory authority from the
legislature our hands are tied you're
the Insurance Commissioner you should
have some power to do something we are
asking for that power until then
homeowners like Francis feel powerless
one fire away from financial disaster so
do you feel betrayed betrayed this
week's fires will surely bring a flood
of new claims and insurance isn't just
important for rebuilding it's required
if you have a home with a mortgage and
just imagine trying to sell a home in a
fire risk area that's virtually
uninsurable for CBS this morning
Saturday Carter Evans Los Angeles I
lived in California I understand what
it's like to live on the coastline in
the Hills I mean danger everywhere you
go yeah I heard about every time I was
out there covering wildfires past couple
years
I mean hurricanes also this yeah heard
you an issue a flooding issue also any
River if you live along it you're in
danger flood zones